this is a country that is falling apart
day by day we wanted a move from one
area of the capital Porto Prince to
another Crossing two rival gang
territories
Sky News contacts insisted we had a
police escort
machine guns ready they cleared a way
through it is that bad
the officers were wary 10 policemen were
killed here in the last week
Haiti has been bad for years but this is
a new development there is now no
elected controlling Authority at all
some countries are actively considering
sending in foreign soldiers to impose
order
Prince is a seething mass of desperate
people sixty percent of the city is
under gang control
there are over 100 groups and that is
who the international thoughts would
face
after weeks of negotiation we were
Guided by a motorcycle rider Into the
Heart of one of the most notorious
gang-controlled areas
we came to meet a man known to everyone
as barbecue
he says sending in foreign forces would
be a disaster
um
is a former policeman he's under
sanctions from the UK for his actions
here but he does remain one of the most
powerful people in Haiti today and he
doesn't like being interrupted
hey
[Music]
constantly escorted by machine gun
toting guards he told me the threat of
an organized hit on him is permanent he
survived four attempts already
it's the blue building yeah
barbecue is the leader of One of a
collective of gangs called the G9
they are very powerful but not powerful
enough to take on the other 91 gangs
AU today
so if you were to just go through here
now
would they would shoot yeah
so barbecue and his men control their
area police it and Patrol it is
hard to explain but this is like a
castle an inside barbecue is the king
but his enemies are only one wall away
before
he dispenses Bunny and largesse he sees
himself as a revolutionary fighting
against the dark Corruption of
government and oligarch businessmen but
he is a gang leader and is always under
attack Porto Prince is a war zone every
minute
the edges of their territory are clearly
marked and he rarely goes beyond them
what's really incredible actually is the
sense of being in in a war zone actually
going through back alleys to get between
the front lines which are around the
corner it's like being in Aleppo it's
like being in mosul it's uh it's quite
remarkable actually you've got so many
factions so many gangs fighting each
other and their territories are very
specific
ironically it is safer for us to film
here in this gang control territory that
in most of the rest of the city where we
could easily be kidnapped or killed that
that is something that every single
person lives with here every single day
it's your Ramsey Sky news reporter
Prince